when i was a little kid i thought that
people did bad things because they were
in cahoots with the devil that's what i
thought and then when i got a little
older i said oh that's crazy
they no it's not because they're in
cahoots with the no it's the devil
doesn't he doesn't even exist and it's
just the people are just following their
own individual choices and exercising
their autonomy and and then when i got a
little bit older still i realized
no they just do bad things because
they're in cahoots with the devil it's
amazing how you go
you go right back to where you were you
had it right the first time actually so
my producers
found these videos on tick tock there
were videos of people making pro
abortion arguments because that's the
hottest topic around right now so hot
right now that is the central
issue of debate in the united states and
they they did it they kind of said the
quiet part out loud when it comes to the
devil and the evil and all the spiritual
components so i am now tasked with
figuring out which one of these
pro-abortion advocates is the most
explicitly
satanic abortions
this video is brought to you by ring
more from ring in just a second first
though let's get to the satanists
[Music]
we have a big win for the pro-choice
community right now as of this week
abortions are protected by religious
liberty laws for satanists and this is
due to the religious freedom restoration
act of 1993. this act ensures that the
interests and religious freedom are
protected you might be wondering why
these all tie in together but let me
tell you satan's now have an abortion
ritual feel free to pause and read but
it basically sanctifies the abortion
process by instilling confidence and
protecting bodily autonomy rights when
undergoing the safe and scientific
procedure so the following requirements
cannot be forced on satanist
[Music]
and any abortions in the first trimester
we are allowed to obtain there's also
this form that you can print off and
submit to ensure that your rights are
protected in addition to those there are
some affirmations that you do with the
rituals as well that basically just help
you be empowered in yourself and you can
look those up on the website thyself is
thy master and hail satan
okay so this this gal like all people
who have ever gotten in cahoots with the
devil thinks that she's being really
clever it's like i have espn or
something and she says well i want there
to be legal abortion and
they want to get rid of legal abortion
but i'm going to claim there's a
religious liberty right to legal
abortion yes see because of religious
liberty in here i'm going to be able to
avoid pro-life laws because the
satanists oh yeah could you believe what
a strange coincidence the satanists are
actually now supporting abortion what a
isn't that a wild coincidence this girl
seems to think that she's stumbled on a
kind of wild quirky little isn't that so
strange it's not strange at all it's not
strange at all and even there she says
look i i'm all about satanism because
that just means doing what you want
satanism doesn't mean you really think
there's a little red guy with horns and
a and a spear or anything like that no
it just means doing whatever you want to
do and
you know pursuing your own desires
yeah that's what it always meant
that's what it always meant and don't
you think it's a little strange
that you who you think you're just
exercising your own liberal
totally rationalistic enlightened free
will don't you think it's a little weird
that
it always just leads you right back to
doing all the same weird devil worship
stuff that people have been doing for
thousands of years isn't that doesn't
that give you a little bit of pause i
guess not her okay next one up the
satanic temple wants to ensure you can
still get an abortion with the
possibility of roe vs wade being
overturned the satanic temple want to
use the rfra to make sure its members
can still perform abortion rituals which
if you're wondering is just a normal
abortion they might also open abortion
clinics the rfra essentially defines
protections for the freedom of religion
in the united states
if the christian church can force
pro-life law why can't the satanic
temple do the opposite uh well for a few
reasons uh one there's more of us than
there are of them and this is
self-government and we have some say
over how we run our country there are
dozens of us
dozens uh two we have legal protections
and
i think constitutional protections to
protect life we don't have any
constitutional protections no real
constitutional protections
for killing little babies and three
because there's a difference between
good and evil there's a difference
between god and the devil and we should
pursue the good and avoid evil we seem
to have forgotten this in recent years
where we pretend that politics is
totally neutral and we can't make any
distinctions even self-styled
conservative thinkers and writers have
suggested that we can never tell the
difference between say drag queen story
hour and a church on sunday the public
needs to be totally neutral to these two
things uh no
no we actually can tell the difference
okay
and this this was an important aspect of
our country for the vast majority of our
country's history there are limits to
religious liberty the satanists think
they're being clever
by defining any evil action that they
want
as a part of their religious ritual well
let's take it all the way
it's actually the exact same claim that
they're making here with abortion but
we'll take it in a way that will make it
clearer to other people if the satanic
temple came out and said one of our
rituals is that we
sacrifice 16 year old virgin girls and
we sacrifice those virgin girls to the
devil and that's our religious ritual
and therefore we have a right to do it
no one would take that argument
seriously at no point in the history of
this country or any other country would
that be thought to be some protected
aspect of religious liberty
unfortunately human sacrifice has been a
part of the public religion of lots of
countries over the years and and it's
actually part of the kind of public
religion of our country now except
instead of a 16 year old we're talking
about a six month old or a three month
old or a 10 week old or a nine month old
or you know babies that are in the womb
there are obviously limits on this the
satanists don't have the right to do
whatever they want as far as i'm
concerned they don't have very many
rights at all you know summer is always
busy so you know we go on vacation we
leave the house and we want to make sure
that we're protected we can rest easy
you can do that with ring alarm you know
about ring ring is that amazing video
doorbell where you can see and speak to
whoever is at your door whether you're
in the home or outside the home or at
the office well ring also has an alarm
so you can protect your entire home the
windows the doors everything from freeze
fire flood all the bad guys well now
you can go pro ring alarm pro is the
next level security system cnet calls
ring alarm pro a giant leap for home
security and after seeing this in action
i absolutely think that they are right
ring has combined the home security
system with a wi-fi router because you
live your life in the physical world so
you got to protect that but you live a
lot of your life in the digital world
you got to protect that too okay with a
ring pro subscription which is an
amazing deal by the way you get
professional monitoring for the ultimate
peace of mind if anything happens
professional monitoring will call and
request emergency services totally
worry-free time away from the home to
learn more go to ring.com
michael all right back to the satanists
so today i've decided to end the
abortion debate and i'm going to start
off with agreeing with you pro-lifers so
yes life begins at conception a fetus is
a living baby and it deserves all the
rights everybody else has on the face of
the planet well if we agree then why are
we arguing and yet you still can't ban
abortion and here's why it's called
bodily autonomy and bodily autonomy
dictates that nobody can be forced to
share or give up their body against
their will even if he causes the death
of another person that means that body
autonomy takes precedence over another
person's right to live so no you can't
be forced to give up a kidney or a liver
or even your blood against your will
even if your decision causes somebody
else to die same thing goes with women's
bodies they don't have to give up their
body or their uterus or go through hours
or even days of intense pain while
they're literally being torn apart to
let it a baby against their will it's
their body
their choice just because that she makes
that claim doesn't make it true
right she says well what they're
forgetting you see is that we have
bodily autonomy
uh no you don't you have some bodily
autonomy but you do not have absolute
bodily autonomy you don't have a natural
right you don't have a constitutional
right you don't even have a civil right
to do just anything you want with your
body at any given time certainly not you
don't you do not have that right with
your body if you wanted to go on the
internet and download child pornography
that's just it's your body right it's
your body it's your computer it's your
autonomy you're not allowed to do that
there are limits on what you're allowed
to do if you wanted to uh kill yourself
if you wanted to commit suicide you are
not allowed to do that in certain states
now they're trying to make that legal
the only reason they have to make that
legal is because it's illegal because
you don't have the right to do that you
do not have total bodily autonomy stop
breaking the law
the madness of this perspective
comes because and this woman probably
came by it honestly
because she's thinking of politics
primarily from the standpoint of rights
where by the way even if you think in
this very liberal way from the
standpoint of rights her argument
doesn't make sense because she's saying
basically that liberty the freedom of
the woman to do what she wants trumps
the life of the baby
that's not true when we talk about life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
it's not like those are all on equal
footing
one derives from the other you can't
pursue happiness without liberty you
can't have liberty without life and so
in a conflict between those rights even
by the the
liberal framework still life would have
to trump it but i think that's a dumb
way to look at politics to begin with i
don't think politics is primarily about
rights whether it's your natural rights
or your civil rights or your
constitutional rights i think those
things are important but it's primarily
about
duty obligation i have obligations i'm
born not as some free-floating automaton
some adam in in the sky that uh is
absolutely able to do whatever i want
because i have no connections to anyone
no i'm born to a mother to a family in a
community where i have responsibilities
right i have to respect people
in a nation in in a moral order i have
responsibilities ultimately to my god so
no you don't
you don't have the right to just do
whatever you want to your body whenever
you want to do it you can make that
claim that you do but you haven't
explained why that is and you're making
a claim that
statistically no one has ever believed
anywhere in the entire history of the
world that all pretty much all of moral
philosophy would say is not
not true okay last one if you have a
uterus and you do not like these
abortion laws keep listening so this is
for my americans really we have our
constitution rights our first amendment
right so the first amendment is
basically freedom of speech and freedom
to practice religion
that being said if you join the satanic
temple you will have control over your
body so in satanism they practice the
seven fundamentals
number three if you want to read that
basically it means you cannot infringe
on somebody's body and that if they want
to do something they have the right to
do it to themselves here's a org article
about the satanic temple suing texas so
basically all you have to do is go on to
the satanic temple's website and you
have to buy a membership thingy it's 25
this thing
so as long as you have physical proof
that you're part of the satanic temple
you can do whatever you want to your
body you can get an abortion even if the
law say no so that's just not true it's
a total fabrication that's one of those
things like they go around social media
sometimes which is you have to post this
text that says that mark zuckerberg
can't look at your pictures or else she
won't be pretending that's just not true
she's not making
anything resembling a legally coherent
argument but she is raising a good point
which is on this question of religious
liberty she says the first amendment
says that you can have whatever
religious practices you want absolutely
that's not what the first amendment says
she is implying i think that there is a
firm separation between church and state
that's not true that has never been true
from the very beginning of our country
onward that is plucked pretty much out
of thin air actually what does the first
amendment say it says that there will be
no established church at the national
level do you know why that is not to
protect the government from the church
it's because there already were
established churches at the state level
in most of the states there were state
establishments that continued for
decades after the constitution was
ratified that's why in the united states
we've had blasphemy laws for a lot of
our nation's history you didn't have the
right to blaspheme god don't take the
lord's name in vain i'm sorry even john
locke john locke is the father of
liberalism we supposedly take so much of
our country from john locke in john
locke's letter concerning toleration
john's lock says that we should tolerate
everybody and give people free speech
except for atheists who should not be
tolerated whatsoever and should
basically just be ostracized
that's that's the great father of
liberalism the great proponent of
freedom of religion it's just they're
making arguments that are not only
philosophically inconsistent but just
completely ahistorical they don't have
any basis in the actual american or
western tradition at all
so who is the most satanic
i kind of feel bad for that last girl i
appreciated the even though she does
have the little devil kind of horn thing
in her nose which
on a superficial level makes her
probably the most satanic i appreciated
the the british lady who talked about
bodily autonomy it's called bodily
autonomy i felt that she at least was
trying to be honest the most satanic is
that first one thy self is thy master in
helsinki she said you know the only the
only commandment that there is is do
what you will one it's incoherent
because we want contrary things
for instance if i
have just eaten
three pieces of pie
and i see there's that last little slice
of chocolate pie i want to eat that pie
part of me wants to eat that pie but
part of me does not want to eat that pie
part of me says michael you're gonna
feel really bad and get fat and it's
gonna you're not you shouldn't eat that
pie
so how do how do we do i i want it and i
don't want it well that's because human
beings have two wills we have the lower
will which is known as the appetite
that's what animals have what the hell
with it
and we have the rational will which
distinguishes us from the lower animals
and the rational will is the mediator
between the appetite the lower will and
the divine will the transcendent moral
order that uh that we all have some
sense of and so the the rational will
tells us no don't eat that pie that
would be wrong the rational will says no
don't cheat on your wife the rational
will says no don't steal that car note
even if part of some lower part of you
wants to do that okay and so when when
the satanists say do what you will
they're not talking about the rational
will okay they're not they're certainly
not talking about the divine will
they're rejecting that they're saying
just pursue all your basis appetites
whatever perversions you have whatever
gluttonous lusts of your loins and
stomach you have just just follow those
things that leads to misery that that
does not make you a free person actually
the whole point of liberal education is
to tamp down and tame that appetite that
that makes you the very same as as any
other animal and to cultivate the higher
will that's why we call it the liberal
arts is to cultivate freedom and that's
what true freedom is whereas the man who
sins is a slave to sin we used to
understand that and and we seem to have
forgotten that as a culture certainly on
tick tock they've forgotten that so the
first lady is the most satanic all the
rest of you do not just do whatever you
will do what god wills do what is right
do that and you'll have a much better
life and we'll have a much better
society and uh we won't need to deal
with all the kooky satanists on tick
tock at least not as much
i'm michael and also see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you